hey what's up guys mkbhd here and how
about those chromebooks huh many of us
have thought that chromebooks were a
dead or dying breed but one of them has
been the number one best-selling laptop
on amazon since the first day that it
was introduced so what's going on here
chromebooks have been doing really well
as very cheap but also very easy to use
laptops they're basically a 250 laptop
that you can get for mom or grandma or
something like that and it just runs
google chrome you can use all the chrome
web apps and everything like that and
it's been doing pretty well just as a
basic product like that a couple of
weeks ago a very interesting video came
out
that sort of showed a high-end looking
chromebook with a sort of a retina
display and all these really interesting
things that we would have loved to see
but never really happened but it was
sort of dismissed as sort of a non-real
product but yesterday google came out
with announced and made available the
chromebook pixel it's real and uh looks
sort of a bit like a squared off macbook
pro it looks good and the specs are
actually high-end so start off with the
display that's basically the highlight
of the hardware this thing's called the
chromebook pixel because it is a 13-inch
2560x1700 display which gives it a pixel
density of 239 pixels per inch that
makes it the number one highest pixel
density on any laptop display out there
it's also a three by two aspect ratio
which you might think is a little bit
weird especially if you're going to do
media consumption on this thing but when
you think about it it's a chromebook
you're going to be using this thing
entirely for web browsing and media
consumption and for that extra vertical
pixels are better than not enough
especially when pretty much every
website scrolls down you want to be able
to fit as many things as possible on
that display so the extra pixels are
definitely helpful and then it's a 400
nit display that's the brightness level
this here happens to be a 300 display
and it's a high-end display so the
display on the chromebook pixel is
already very high-end and it's touch
screen so the touch screen layer adds a
whole new level of interaction and sort
of immediate experience you can you know
tap it just like it was sort of an
android tablet you can tap to play and
pause videos you can tap to actually
click the way you'd use a mouse the sort
of the same way we've seen windows 8
touchscreen laptops so this is
absolutely a really high-end display and
that's probably why they named it the
chromebook pixel inside is a dual core
1.8 gigahertz core i5 processor with
integrated graphics and around the
outside it does look pretty good it's
made of anodized aluminum it has two usb
2.0 ports a mini display port and an sd
card reader and up top is an hd webcam
there is a wi-fi only version of this
guy for 32 gigs and that's basically
1300
and there's an lte version of this guy
that has 64 gigs of storage all the
links for that will be down below right
below the like button on this video so
it seems like in terms of pure specs
this thing is shooting at the 13-inch
retina macbook pro plus a touch screen
but then you consider the fact that this
entire package fits in a 3.4 pound body
that's just 16.2 millimeters thick which
is actually thinner and lighter than
that 13-inch macbook pro there's been a
lot of talk about the price of the
chromebook pixel at thirteen hundred
dollar base price it seems a little bit
high very high actually but when you
think about it
it still seems very high let's take a
step back and consider the purpose of
this machine the real reason it actually
exists right now and for that we take a
look at a quote from google's blog which
says this brings together the best in
hardware and software and design to
inspire the next generation of
chromebooks
this is a halo product this is the nexus
10 and the nexus 4 of chromebooks this
is the inspiration for the next hardware
manufacturers to start making
chromebooks that are actually high-end
and from high-end specs right now all
we've seen so far is 250 and 300 cheap
plastic hp and sort of basic chromebooks
this is the inspiration for the next
generation of high-end chromebooks so in
its creation it's not even really made
for the typical consumer it's not made
to sell well it's not a flagship it's
just a chromebook so what is the real
purpose of this chromebook pixel well
gene lewis guyan on google plus put it
best in his post
the chromebook pixel is really just an
experiment but it's one that's crucial
for chrome os it may not sell well at
all in fact it probably won't and the
chrome team may not care how well it
sells after all what they will watch
closely is what happens next
specifically in the chrome web store
this is similar to what this nexus one
did for android consider the two biggest
complaints you've heard about
chromebooks in the past few years one
it's cheap hardware and two it lacks
powerful apps so the critics have called
it just a glorified web browser and to
them the chromebook pixel looks exactly
the same as the rest most early reviews
will conclude that it's too expensive or
the hardware is premature but as we've
seen repeatedly in blog posts and videos
from google the pixel really is for
what's next what today's announcement
shows is google has chosen to address
hardware first in doing so on its own
they're not relying on samsung or acer
or hp or anyone else and they're doing
so boldly no longer are chromebooks
synonymous with budget hardware they can
be cutting edge and specs are no longer
an excuse now we have high end hardware
so now the hardware is out of the way
chrome os really needs to step up it
needs cutting-edge applications to make
it more than just a glorified web
browser the chrome team has known this
for a while and they certainly know it
today it's the missing element what they
need it's what consumers have said are
keeping them from adopting chrome os or
switching completely from windows or mac
users need powerful productivity apps
and games and even photo and video
editing apps and the web store has to be
better it has to offer that the
groundwork has now been laid over all
these years with the cheap chromebooks
and google needs the developers to make
the rest happen they also need a
chromebook to get excited about that's
the pixel so over the next few months
you'll see google doing its best to get
the pixel in the hands of and the minds
of as many developers as possible in
fact the pixel will probably be given
out for free to developers at google i o
this year meanwhile the chrome team will
continue to push development until the
web is all users really need reducing
hardware dependencies and bringing in
things from android like notifications
and google now so when the apps become
powerful enough and the pixel is
powerful enough chromebooks will become
more than just a glorified web browser
in the eye of the mainstream consumer
and that is the gamble that google made
today
so in the end the chromebook pixel is a
halo product it is sort of a beginning
and a sort of an entry into a new market
that doesn't really exist yet but it's
google pioneering away where it wants
others to follow it's paving that path
that it wants manufacturers of other
chromebooks to start to follow to make
high-end new generation of chromebooks
and the reason sadly that it is so
expensive is that touchscreen it's that
better be a really good touch screen in
order for it to be so expensive my
biggest problem with touchscreen laptops
was actually pressing it the hinge would
bend and it would wobble back and forth
this needs to be a great touch screen to
justify me paying 1300 for it now all
that being said i still haven't held one
yet i haven't actually held it so expect
a video on it coming up in the next few
days when i get my hands on one until
then i will leave you with my chrome os
explained video which is down below
first link in the description but yeah
that's it so hopefully i'll see you guys
in the next video and this was the
chromebook pixel explained thank you for
watching and i'll talk to you guys later
peace
so
you